tomorrow's your day to die what's your
last meal
filthy dirty buttery potatoes with a
beautiful sauvignon blanc from the
marlboro region of new zealand and old
school prawn cocktail are you a really
beautiful cut in half avocado with fresh
fine ripe tomatoes and a little bit of
mozzarella and a really good spaghetti
bolognese
[Music]
how did rebecca come into your life i
got the pilot sent through in a kind of
secret squirrel
it's one of those like weird
way you can't you can see this but you
can't on one device yeah you know it
exists but you don't
and um
yeah i wasn't told
what it was for
who it was for who'd created it nothing
but that actually
afforded me the luxury to just go oh who
is this woman
at face value
that's the first time i think ever
because it was so secret squirrel do you
have is there a different expression in
american for that like secret badger or
something um it's just like top secret
right it's almost like i'm not secret
squirrel
no but i love that yeah
um
yeah i just learned learnt all the sides
and and went into town to a casting and
i don't know about you
but i just i i go faber david
leave what you think is the best you can
do on camera and i always come out and
tear it up me too because also you want
to leave it in the room when it's that
top secret yeah yeah i don't want you
going back
in my recycling oh my god because if
that gets my name on it exactly i'd kind
of forgotten about it and went back to
being mama picking my girl up from
school and then the day it they said no
you've got it i had to go and pick my
daughter up from school walk through the
very very normal playground and not go
oh my god my life just tried
if your house went up in flames what
would be the things you would grab it
would be my girl over my shoulder and
i'm good to go
[Music]
you've known jason for ages haven't you
i knew him for a little while yeah a big
beforehand and i've been working in
europe for about six months got back to
l.a
turned 30 which was epic
don't tell anyone quite a long time for
me 28 forever
but i got a text from jason being like
yo yo uh jason here um got your number
and uh just wanted to chat to you about
something to which i thought
oh he thinks i'm someone else
oh no
oh no i love your faith in you so yeah
well i'm working on that but so then he
i was like hey what can i do for you
and he said well i actually have this
pilot that i would love you to read if
you have a moment or if you'd be
interested it's something that i'm
reaching
out to you personally about because it
means a lot to me and so i was like are
you kidding me quietly thinking what if
it's not meant for me like this is a
disaster so i did read it and i just
thought it was such an unusual pilot i
hadn't read anything like it because it
made you laugh and also made you feel
really emotional from the get-go you
know
and so then i called him and when he
said hey juno i was like oh
there has been no conflict for me
you and i come from two such totally
different comfort zones you are nervous
doing comedy which nobody would believe
on camera and i come from the world of
theater
big cell was he did talk to me about
this relationship between the two of us
which was one that first and foremost he
was really passionate about and really
cared about these two women helping each
other in ways they didn't know were even
possible so you knew about i didn't know
anything about i knew that there was
going to be a
that blossomed and i didn't know the
specifics of it like when i read that
script that where it immediately is
about you naked on a yacht and that's so
specific and i push you push you and
push you to see it because i'm like come
on you're dying to show something
and that moment of you kind of being
like oh
yeah she should be proud of my yeah as a
woman and special where it is on this
couch right here isn't it like rebecca
in her formality even the shape of what
that scene looked like and it's a real
turning point and i think it's the first
time in a while that rebecca has heard a
compliment from a female that she's
believed i felt in that moment because
i'm not sure either of these women have
experienced
love and friendship like you say from
another female and very much of
different generations it feels like
they're kind of soul mates but they
didn't know that until episodes start
progressing and by the end of season one
i truly believe that and then there's
the twist that happens at the end i know
we've talked about being able to call
each other out being accountable yeah
but it's scary isn't it and i think like
as two women sitting here talking about
these characters we can relate to them
on such
deep levels i know you can your your
insight into rebecca as a woman is
something i
watch as we've done press together about
it and learning about how much she meant
to you
in a deep deep way that makes you have
such an understanding of her which is
why she is such an extraordinary
character in this when you first started
playing rebecca do you feel like they
made her more
in tune with hannah
yeah i think i felt a shift around the
oh my god the scene at the gala outside
with you and jason yeah that was
probably more personal than anything
yeah it was yeah because i think we're
on camera yeah i think by then jace i
mean he was lit you know what he's like
fiddling around with scripts and writing
up against a wall with brett s l world i
mean yeah lines like that yeah i bulked
at that i was like oh my god you can't
give me something like
10 minutes before we're going to be on
camera
and he still did because he knew that i
was limiting myself and i was just like
this is getting ridiculous how close to
my life this has been our girlfriends
are the most important people
they ground us they save our lives and
hopefully we do the same for them
undoubtedly
[Music]
just the
grace and ease of which you are a mother
you are
an extraordinary actress and you are a
woman in a way that i
i'm excited to grow up and be a woman
because of it i think it's a very
inspirational package no one could have
played this character rebecca bader you
know that but you know that because you
understand that you know i'm horrendous
with compliments but i feel the same
about you and it's and i can't believe
my luck that you were even back for
season two i thought she's so big time
she'll be like off and off suddenly
they'll i'll suddenly hear juna's not
coming back to this no no because she's
doing this giant thing somewhere she
saved my mental health i wouldn't want
to miss this for the world this whole
cast this crew like everybody this
character is like
sure i love the darkness you know i do
but i also when we say here the big time
i get stopped in a grocery store
somebody like hey did i go to school
with you oh no i've just seen your boobs
in a movie and you're like over at
cheerios in the trader joe's or
something it's like i know but i've told
you before you have to celebrate the
fact that people say that because they
are magnificent great all of it is i
mean it's touched
but i think the fact that we get to do
it one more time is like
thank god i was literally just about to
say what does that make you feel about
rapping on season two
proud but also really nervous because
you're just like
you just want to make people proud now
that we know about the success of season
one you just hope that people also
respond to it in a way that
they love our character journeys and
still connect with them in a way that
they did with season one even if they
bring different emotions and new yeah i
think season two is
quite different in terms of
really
getting into the dirt yeah exactly the
human side of it which we all bottle up
that we don't necessarily want to talk
about i think they should have a jelly
fight in season three and really go for
it or a pillow fight in a hotel room
just keep wishing
[Music]
our extraordinary female writers do us
such a great service yeah you know and
one storyline in particular that i have
this year i even spoke to jason about it
and i was like who's mainly responsible
for this and he said well they are in
there and i was like
i need to go and give them a squeeze and
go come on the girls because it's just
blindsided me and i love that they have
literally gone go on do that that gets
you shut comfortable don't be shy
they're very brave big time and the most
important female that's joined us this
year
is magnificent sarah niles and i would
like to genuinely put in a bit of a
complaint in fact i did jason i was like
i would have liked to have more to do
with her because yes the stuff we did in
here with sarah i was like
the first read-through that we had on
zoom and she started reading that
character of a therapist sports
therapist and i was like she brought a
very
chilled out effortless power
and is a brilliant foil to where yours
and my characters are but also has an
arc that audiences be excited because
again as per usual with ted lasso don't
judge a book by its cover
maybe this time next year we'll be able
to have her on the couch too yes
i will never forget that moment where
somebody said to us this is a show i
want to show my daughter because of the
relationship you two have created and it
really took the wind out of us both
didn't it that's the highest compliment
we could get
you